[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we received many questions about hitman
and the elusive target in particular
many people want to know the parameters
for restarting an elusive target we've
compiled 9 typical scenarios and we'll
use our myth-busting skills to determine
when you can indeed restart an elusive
target I'll be using the surgeons which
was the elusive target in February if
this is of you please do with a favor
and give us a like and maybe subscribe
too okay let's do this can I restart
after being spotted by civilians and non
and fallen athlete for this one we'll
jump over the balcony and hang on to the
ledge of course the NPC is freaked out
and we have in fact committed a crime as
he runs off to report us to the
authorities we can pause the game and
see that we can both restart the mission
or replan it so yes you can restart the
mission if a civilian spots you next up
can we restart if we've been spotted by
CCTV well let's try it there should be a
CCTV camera over here and yeah in the
top left corner it now says you have
been recorded by a security camera let's
pause the game and once again yes we can
certainly restart storage question three
can I restart - being hunted to test
this will beat up this guard in full
view of staff and guests above our radar
you can see we are now being hunted
I'll even wait a little bit for the gap
to see us face to face before pausing
and once again yep we can still restart
the location next question can I restart
after killing someone
this one is easy but comes with a caveat
if the person is not the target then yes
you can kill them and indeed still
restart the mission our next scenario
can I restart after changing my attire
let's murder eyes the guest and steal
their clothing
I'll even run outside to be spotted by
other people the answer is yes of course
we can restart very next up people
wanted to know if we can restart after
being shot story so let's try it I'll
plunge a scientist in the face and we'll
see how the guards react they're
definitely taking fire so I'll pause and
yes once again we can restart these
final three questions are quite
important so let's break these down can
I restart the elusive target if I have
killed the target well we shall endeavor
to try here's our target we can indeed
push him over the edge and kill him off
the cliff the crime has been noticed too
so I'll wait till we are being hunted as
well I press pause and look we cannot
restart an elusive target if we have
killed one of our marks if we try to
exit to menu we are told we will fail
the elusive target so let's get around
this issue we can either turn off the
console or simply close the application
and reopen it again once loaded you can
indeed restart the mission again this is
exactly the same when you have other
parameters such as picking up a memory
stick so remember do not click exit
mission into that it close the
application and restart hit run again
can I restart the elusive target after
dying simply put if you die the mission
is over and you have failed but there is
a trick you can utilize I do not
recommend this but if you are quick
enough you can pull out the ethernet
cable from the back of your console or
PC and you can stop the online server
from knowing that you died a puppet will
say that you have been disconnected and
at this point do not press retry you
want to click go to main menu and once
you've done that feel free to plug back
in your Ethernet cable and try the
mission again I personally use a Wi-Fi
signal and cannot use this technique but
just to reiterate I do not recommend
this finally can I restart if the
elusive target escapes the location this
is a really good question which I could
not recreate in the current mission I
mean I tried punching this guy throwing
object at ease
and I even tried following him around
and killing everyone in his vicinity
sadly I could not get him to run for the
exit but I can report 100% that if your
target makes it to an exit
you cannot restart the mission if you
think your target has made a run for the
exit then quickly restart your mission
or if you are slightly too late
try use the ethernet trick explained
earlier but you want though if you
aren't quick enough then the failed
target will forever be on your record so
I'm hoping that was of some help and you
will never fail an elusive target again
please start with a like and maybe
subscribe for more hitman content I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade I'll see
you next time
[Music]